This video is sponsored by movement
watches in sunglasses,
more on movement.
At the end of this video,
hey,
for one disembodied jared here,
back to talk to you about the Merc with
a mouth.
Now,
deadpool probably means a lot to you.
It's sharp wit is a welcome reprieve
from a torrent of superhero movies.
Nobody's getting hurt and we're sure
dead pool two will be no different,
but I'm here to talk about something
else.
Not only,
as we've mentioned previously,
is dead pull a kind of microcosm for the
ironic distance that pervades our
culture,
but it represents a lot more.
Does deadpool hold the secret to how
people can get you to buy more stuff?
Welcome to this Blob,
blah,
and no spoilers ahead this time.
Can we say that?
Let's begin our story with the most
recent adverts for deadpool two,
the teaser at the beginning of Logan and
the wet on wet trailer.
Both of these succeed free,
very simple reason.
They actively refuse to do what normal
promotional material should do in the
Logan teaser.
Deadpool takes too long changing in a
phone booth while a hapless civilian
gets brutally assaulted.
In the end,
he's too late,
but being honest with myself,
I probably should have just called nine
one one.
The whole thing pokes fun at one of our
cultures.
Oldest icons,
superman and for good measure,
a random essay about the old man in the
seat.
We're still scratching our heads at that
one.
Maybe it has something to do with Logan
and Santiago,
sacrificial nature.
I Dunno.
In the trailer,
wet on wet deadpool.
Don's a sweet fro in a soothing
Baritone,
imitating Bob Ross's the joy of painting
even before Deadpool,
our cultural obsession with Bob Ross has
always included a little dose of irony
and if you tell them,
and it wasn't that,
that bushes there,
I will come to your house and I will cut
you.
The wholesome public television show
full of dad humor and happy little trees
became an internet sensation.
It's naive.
Authenticity became a joke for
disillusion.
Millennials,
I'm not a very good fisherman.
I catch a little fish and take the hook
carefully out of his mouth.
Put a bandaid on him going the CTR patty
one to two two and putting back in the
water
in wet on wet.
The colors are movie jokes.
Bob Ross's very real obsession with
whacking his brushes is highlighted.
What's that often shake off the excess
and just beat the devil out of.
That's really the most fun part of it
and the chief engineer is one jury La
Forge.
Both of these are awesome,
right?
When I saw them in theaters,
people were losing their shit,
but is there something more to it than
just,
it's funny if anything,
these promotions are anti promotions by
flaunting their absurdity.
They mostly avoid teasing the actual
movie they're promoting held.
The first deadpool movie marketed itself
as a Romcom at one point.
Surprise.
This is actually lucky.
You are love story.
Instead of promises of cool fight scenes
in a suspenseful plot.
The whole pre logan trailer just raises
doubts about Super Harrowing in general
is a phone booth doing on a street
corner and wet on wet has a real trailer
packed on the end of a series of not so
subtle in you with no relation to the
movie itself.
It just get high and all laughs
splendor.
God,
I love cocaine and here's the point.
The secret of self promotion in 2017 is
to make fun of the very fact that you're
being self promotional.
That's supposed to sell deodorant.
Talk about something real like the
smooth,
sophisticated center mall spice.
The secret is cynicism,
but to understand why this is uniquely
successful today,
we have to turn back to a guy who lived
in a barrel and made philosophy out of
pissing in public dialogue.
He needs,
the cynic was one of the progenitors of
Western cynical philosophy.
It's disputed whether or not he's the
reason we use the term cynicism to
describe his school philosophy,
but the term cynic,
which in Greek means dog,
like what's at the very least an insult
hurled.
At diageo,
he's by his contemporaries,
but either way,
he really embraced the term and made a
habit of urinating and fornicating in
public just like our four legged
friends,
never one to half ass anything.
Even tried eating raw meat,
not unlike our foul mouth.
Tiro Dodge and he spent his time
berating the customs and habits of his
peers,
whereas dead pool may successfully type
cast his peers,
oh,
come on,
it'll leave me all alone here with less
angry rosie o'donnell.
They are genies would do things like
stop on Plato's carpet yelling.
I trample on the pride of plato running
into Plato's classroom with a plump
chicken screaming,
behold Plato's man and ordering his
remains three thrown over the city wall
so that wild animals could feast on his
corpse.
The point for [inaudible] was to be
relentlessly cynical toward the habit
and customs of the well to do with
Finian's if they viewed themselves as
noble purveyors.
Of Truth.
Dow Ginny's would carry around a lantern
in broad daylight telling those around
him.
He was searching for an honest man if
they thought defecating in public was
beneath the dignity of a civilized man,
die jays would drop trau right in the
middle of the [inaudible].
It's not an entirely different than
these superhero that refuses to be a
hero.
Ooh,
and Cherry Garcia ice cream.
I can eat this,
but
despite their similarities,
deadpool and diage needs are
fundamentally different.
At least according to the logic of
philosopher Peter slaughter died for
slaughter dyke.
If diageo has represented a pointed
criticism of his contemporaries,
cynicism today has become universal and
diffuse permeating every aspect of our
culture.
News,
film,
Video Games are all made cynically,
and we even perform our jobs with a
cynical indifference.
The logic boils down to,
hey,
at least it's a paycheck on a global
scale.
Slaughter Dyke was writing in the 1980s
but he might as well have been riding
today if diageo needs publicly performed
in such a way to rid the world of bad
ideas.
Modern cynicism is merely a resignation
to the fact that everything is terrible
and while deadpool is perfect proof of
universal cynicism,
that doesn't actually change anything.
Also consider the steady stream of self
aware advertising that succeeds by
virtue that it rejects it's berry
premise.
Men.
Lebron James made a sprite commercial
for the super bowl where he ironically
and repeatedly affirms the,
he'll never tell you to drink sprite.
Let's get one thing straight.
I'll never tell you to drink sprite.
Even if I wasn't a commercial for
sprite,
which I am.
New Castle made a superbowl ad about how
they couldn't afford a superbowl ad.
Turns out they don't even have the money
or permission to make us more so they
can't even say the word.
Basically,
the only thing I haven't done is a nude
scene and get paid money to be at a
commercial for a beer.
I don't even drink
cards against humanity.
Made a whole black Friday campaign out
of mailing people poop and if mailing
people poop is a metaphor for successful
marketing in our modern age.
Deadpool's advertising is the Creme de
la at her to film promotion.
Hold each of your man berries or as I
like to call them,
smooth criminals,
trailers that aren't trailers.
A superhero who is not a hero.
Per Brazil's comicon.
Deadpool released a video where he
offers a supposedly heartfelt attempt to
connect with his Brazilian fans by
saying the show my dedication to the
yeah
legions of Brazilian deadpool fans.
I've spent up to 20 minutes on Google
translate as well as countless hours
watching Tele novellas to teach me
everything about your official language
before offering up eight clearly not
deadpool,
voiceover
you're goes [inaudible],
[inaudible],
but perhaps nothing exemplifies this
trend.
Like a recent rick and morty old spice
at Rick Sanchez introduces some
anthropomorphize old spice products in a
board monotone before counting neath
thousands of dollars he just made for
the shameless promotion for slaughter
died.
This is what separates modern cynicism
from the cynicism of Diageo.
Our modern economy is compatible with
nothing,
quite so much as the limitations about
the corrupting effect of all mighty
money.
Money makes the world go round.
Isn't that terrible?
What makes this work for advertising to
you?
Slaughter dykes words is that cynicism
is criticism with limited liability.
Deadpool can joke about the budget
constraints of his own movie,
Big House.
It's funny that I only ever see two of
you.
It's almost like the studio couldn't
afford another Eczema
or even its own lead.
I think Ryan Reynolds got this far on
his superior acting method
and in doing so protects itself from any
judgements about budget constraints or
acting resumes for slaughter died.
This is fundamentally different than the
cynicism of diabetes they are needs met
the customs and ideas of his peers with
pure satirical laughter.
It worked because he also constructed an
alternative living like a stray dog out
of a giant barrel.
In response to the contemporary
definitions of citizenship,
he declared he was a citizen of the
world.
Rather,
our modern cynicism lacks any
alternative,
whereas some thinkers posited that the
masses will follow their leaders with a
false consciousness.
A metaphorical wool pulled over their
eyes.
Slaughter Dyke posits that modern
cynicism is enlightened false
consciousness.
We are acutely aware that there is wool
over our eyes,
but we safe get wall is warm and cozy.
Creators may know an advertisement is
stupid,
but on a commercial is so annoying,
but you got a great product or a
superhero trope is overused.
Superhero landing,
so you're going to do a superhero
landing,
but hey,
gotta pay the bills,
right?
Whoa.
Superhero landing.
The alternative is to make a movie that
no one watches or a youtube video.
I'm still hurt about that one.
Yay.
Consider the painting at the end of wet
on wet.
It's an alteration of Norman Rockwell's
freedom from want depicting a wholesome
family ready to eat a giant Merica size
Turkey,
part of his four freedom series based on
the FDR speech.
The message was,
here's what makes America great.
The freedom to pray,
to eat a ton of meat,
to feel safe and to speak your mind.
In typical deadpool fashion,
a wholesome image is robbed of its
original meaning.
This is another microcosm of our cynical
era.
Straightforward defenses of any kind of
values are scorned as naive at best and
at worst are vulnerable to being wrong.
Considered the worst advertisement of
the century.
Pepsi's Kendall Jenner ad we're a can of
diabetes.
Water brings together protesters and
riot cops.
On the one hand we all cringed because
the ad cynically watered down social
movements to sell soda,
but the real mistake was to defend
anything at all,
even if behind the scenes it was
cynical.
If the add added a few do not attempt in
real life or results not guaranteed.
We want of all laugh that such a self
aware add cynical advertising upfront
about its own cynicism is smart
advertising.
It's advertising with limited liability,
so it shouldn't surprise us that figures
like superman,
a symbol of heroism and goodness or
Norman Rockwell's freedom from want draw
the ire of dead pool slaughtered.
I quotes Georg symbol who said,
the more money becomes the sole center
of interest,
the more we see honor and convictions,
talent and virtue,
beauty and health of the soul mobilized
on monies behalf.
The more a mocking and frivolous mood
will arise regarding these values which
are offered for sale for the same kind
of value as goods on the weekly market.
Deadpool is the embodiment of this
frivolous and mocking mood because
heroics and values are for sale.
How are we not supposed to laugh at
them?
Please don't make it super suit green or
animated.
And because there exists no conceivable
way to escape the system,
we criticize like perhaps diageo needs.
The cynic could.
What else are we to do?
Wow.
So what do you think is cynicism and
marketing the best way to advertise
these days?
Well,
let's find out.
Have you decided it's time to step up
your style game?
Why not grab a new watch or a pair of
sunglasses from a movement?
If you're one of the first 200 wise
crack fans to make a purchase at
mvmt.com/wise
crack using the offer code wisecrack
you'll get $15 off your purchase.
Founded on the idea that good style
should never break the bank movement
gives you designer great apparel at
super affordable prices with absolutely
no middleman movements,
watches keep you on time and in style
with classic minimalist designs and high
quality construction all starting at 95
bucks and their sunglasses are equally
as awesome.
Starting at $70 you can get lightweight,
handmade designer quality frames with
the option to polarize most pairs.
So head over to mvmt.com/wise
crack or click the link in the
description.
Be sure to use the discount code wise
crack to get $15 off your purchase.
Free Shipping and returns are included.
Instead of watching me count more cash,
click here to join the movement.
Thanks to Movement for sponsoring this
video and think like what we do and how
we think here at wise crack.
We've recently started a movie podcast
called show me the meaning.
We're having a blast with it,
so check it out in the links in the
description,
and as always,
catch all next time.
Peace.
[inaudible].